hey this is Tyler with Waxahachie Nissan
I just wanted to make a quick video
explaining how you start your vehicle
and you get inside of it whenever your
key fob battery dies if you have a key
fob that's this style maybe it's a three
button a four button or a five button
like I have here these batteries you
know they tend to wear out after a few
years I've taken the battery out of this
key fob so there's no battery inside of
it and I'm gonna show you how to start
the vehicle if your battery is dead in
this case the battery is not gonna be in
the fob at all first to get in there's a
lever in the back of the key right here
you pull the lever over and I'll let you
slide the bladed key out this will let
you turn turn the lock on the driver's
door hand okay so that's how you get
inside the vehicle once you're inside
what you want to do right now the
vehicle won't start I'm holding the
brake pressing this button it shows me
warning key ID incorrect that means the
battery's dead in key this case no
battery like I said so what you want to
do you want to hold the key fob one inch
away from the start button here I'll
hold I have my foot on the brake like
normal and then you just press the
button there and it detects it vehicle
starts you can drive it it's still gonna
say warning key ID incorrect cuz until
you get a new battery if you come up
here to walk to hatching Nissan will get
those replaced for you but please like
and share this video if you know anybody
looking for a new or pre-owned vehicle
my name is Tyler and I'm with walk said
shanise on my phone numbers four six
nine seven six five four eight eight
three I hope this was helpful